bonjour à tous et wahou le nouveau
trailer concernant la saison 3 de
strangers in xv vient tout juste de
sortir et mon dieu ce qu'il me hype
je suis un peu pris de court je vous
cache pas la grosse vidéo prévue pour le
29 concernant le mc hugh pompe tout mon
temps mais je vous propose de faire une
aparté et parler de cette série qui est
incroyable on part donc sur une analyse
du trailer je suis très heureux car pour
le moment mon trois théories sur la
saison 3 tient toujours la route et je
vous conseille vivement d'aller voir
bref analysons chaque plan du trailer la
première scène et je pense celle qui
ouvrira la saison 3 de strangers things
saison qui sera durant l'été 1985
d'où le fait que tout le monde semble
être en vacances et en tenue d'été
dustin semblait être absent puisque les
autres lui souhaite un bon retour à la
maison
peut-être était-il partis en vacances
avec sa mère fort possible néanmoins
chaque détail est très important dans la
série et l'épisode pilote de chaque
saison tease des indices sur la série
enfin la saison concernée la première
saison ouvrait sur le jeu donjons et
dragons et la deuxième sur dig dug ici
nous sommes en présence de robots comme
r2d2 de la saga star wars
alors est-ce que la saison pourrait
tourner autour de cette saga
cinématographique peut-être pourtant
star wars si c'est sorti en 1983 et non
donc j'en doute fort cela vous les
robots pourraient symboliser surtout
l'évolution de la série avec des jouets
plus modernes comme avec le robot
transformers par exemple je pense
vraiment qu'ils sont des indices sur
l'intrigué de la saison
n'hésitez pas à me dire en commentaire
ce qu'il vous évoque ensuite nous
enchaînons sur une scène du poste de
police de hawkins où nous retrouvons
annecy et johnatan dans des tenues très
professionnel aujourd'hui
les acteurs ont grandi et évolué tout
comme leurs personnages comme il est dit
dans le trailer nous ne sommes plus des
enfants il est fort probable que non si
et johnatan soit entrée dans le milieu
professionnel
cependant ils ont l'air d'attendre avec
une certaine crainte au poste ils sont
là pour témoigner de quelque chose
certainement il est fort probable que
ces derniers étaient est victime du
retour du mind flyers et qu'ils veulent
en parler à ou peur le personnage qui
sert un peu de berre à tous dans la
série dans ce plan nous retrouvons joy
que billy pardon en tant que maître
nageur confirmant bien que les aînés
sont rentrés dans la vie active steve
également mais nous allons y revenir
ce dernier semble attirer le regard de
toutes les femmes comme à son habitude
est également la mère de mike mais
introduit aussi un nouveau personnage
qui va devenir récurrent dans la série
dont j'avais parlé dans mon trois
théories une certaine romance vu les
regards pourrait naître entre billy et
cette maître nageuse nous continuons sur
un plan de hooper assis seul à une table
de restaurant est plutôt satisfait
effectivement je pense qu'il est inutile
de tourner autour une romance entre lui
et joyce va clairement naître comme il
était montré en fin de saison 2
cependant ou peur reste seul et le
trailer enchaîne sur joyce inquiète
comme à son habitude j'ai envie de dire
mangeant seule chez elle
peut-être n'est-elle pas prête pour une
nouvelle relation suite à la mort de bob
ou tout simplement aux quarts où il a de
nouveau des problèmes
justement le plan suivant nous montre
mike disant qu'ils ne sont plus des
enfants et s'en allant comme par hasard
en compagnie de lucas dustin et max
tiens il ne manque pas quelqu'un bat wii
wheel
évidemment ce dernier semble ne pas
réussir à grandir et accepter
l'évolution de ses amis après tout il a
subi énormément avec le mind fire et
aujourd'hui plus rien n'est comme avant
il est libéré du monstre mais quelque
chose d'autre le tracasse nous
l'entendons à la voix de mike qui lui
affirme qu'ils ne joueront plus dans son
sous sol ils ont grandi et où il ne veut
pas faire la transition
une fissure dans le groupe va donc très
certainement se
néanmoins un max et heleven quant à elle
semble s'être réconciliées et deviennent
enfin de bonnes amies heleven a
certainement compris que rien ne se
passerait entre mike et max et que
finalement l'été avec lucas
effectivement steve également agrandi et
rentrer dans la vie active mais reste
néanmoins lié à dustin par rapport à la
saison 2 tout comme billy bizarrement
les personnages sont toujours liés steve
introduira un nouveau personnage qui
travaillera à ses côtés au centre
commercial stark out une romance
existera très certainement entre les
deux personnages aussi le coeur de cette
nouvelle saison est clairement
l'expansion économique
hawkins n'est plus une petite ville et
se modernise s'agrandit et cela va être
le coeur de cette prochaine saison
le centre commercial stark out parc
d'attractions bref nous rentrons dans
l'ère moderne
néanmoins les habitants ne semblent pas
être d'accord et manifestent contre
cette expansion et notamment le maire
nouveaux personnages de la série que
nous reverrons en écoutant nous
retrouvons la voix de hooper qui parle à
joyce par rapport à leur relation comme
quoi il veut son bonheur et sa sécurité
leur relation va évoluer c'est sur plan
très intrigant un tueur semble être à la
recherche de quelqu'un dans la galerie
des miroirs je pense mais ce n'est que
mon avis qu'il recherche soit les
enfants qui se cacherait dans la galerie
soit nancy et johnatan ce qui
expliquerait leur venue au poste de
police où peur quant à lui se battraient
face à ce tueur donc si le tueur est en
position de force à rechercher quelqu'un
tu suis sûr que c'est les enfants est
très certainement heleven qui commence à
se faire connaître de plus en plus elle
et ses pouvoirs elle ne sera jamais en
sécurité
preuve que peut-être brender serait de
retour d'ailleurs bizarrement on ne voit
pas cali je trouve ça vraiment très
intrigant enfin nous rentrons dans le
vif du sujet concernant lopssi down et
le mind flyers effectivement cette
entité n'est pas qu'un simple monstres
et ses skis
suite à la saison 2 sa défaite face à
elven ce dernier veut sa vengeance et à
connaissance des pouvoirs de la jeune
enfant comme le prouve le dernier plan
de la saison 2 c'est pourquoi je pense
nous retrouvons heleven entre deux
mondes piéger par le mind flyers qui
veulent à contrôler comme il l'avait
fait avec will be lee semble être
affectés également en se faisant très
certainement mordre par quelque chose
peut-être le monstre de la fin du
trailer il semble d'ailleurs perdre sa
copine dans le trailer peut-être est-ce
dû à ça bref tout le monde semble réuni
pour faire face de nouveau au mind
flyers qui affecte beaucoup le centre
commercial lieu du combat ultime je
pense très certainement pour continuer
pour ceux qui se demanderaient le 4
juillet est la journée d'indépendance
des états unis et du coup la journée qui
déclenchera certainement un sacré bazar
à hopkins comme le prouvent
l'accélération du trailer par la suite
sur ces courts plan nous voyons des rats
courir je pense qu'il aura quelque chose
avec eux je ne saurais dire quoi un
homme étrange qui semble être fasciné
par quelque chose en rapport avec le psy
daoud vu ses vêtements et l'endroit
bref il n'ya pas grand chose
d'intéressant mais surtout des détails
comme le fait que les gaufres sont de
retour et que les veines adorent ça
hooper toujours sur le front un mur
permettant d'accéder au monde parallèle
certainement le retour de lucas au lance
pierre et surtout la chose la plus
intéressante la possession de 96 par le
mind flyers vu son physique et ses yeux
avec une pupille fortement dilatés et
des traits noirs
mais ce n'est d'ailleurs pas la seule un
autre plan très étrange montre deux
femmes inconnues qui semble être possédé
et elle aussi
alors est-ce que le masne flyers
auraient réussi à posséder plus de
personnes cette fois ci c'est ce que je
pense effectivement car les saisons vont
vraiment de façon crescendo steve semble
s'être fait avoir également
ou alors est-ce que billy le raid de
nouveaux tabasser vu la seringue
je pense qu'il s'agit d'une sorte
d'antidote anti man flyers très
certainement on finit sur une nouvelle
créature encore plus terrifiante
provenant de l'obs hayden est bon sens
elles si elles donnent vraiment froid
dans le dos enfin voilà écouter voici
tout ce que j'ai analysé de ce trailer
n'hésitez pas à dire ce que vous vous
avez trouvé d'intrigants dans l'est
en terre c'est une vidéo non prévu mais
je tenais réellement à la faire donc
n'hésitez pas à laisser un gros pouce
bleus à vous abonner pour plus de
strangers singh on en reparlera très
certainement à activer la cloche me
suivre sur twitter
et puis écouté que le lay honneur soit
allez-vous 7 et arguant qu
[Musique]